some things in the world of comics are
so iconic so ingrained in our collective
cultural minds as comic fans that
oftentimes we end up taking them for
granted I'll of course talking about the
Batarang on Cape Joel and join me today
as we take a closer look at the history
of the Batarang it may surprise you to
learn that the Batarang
didn't actually appear in Batman comics
until Detective Comics number 31 in
September 1939 up into that point
Batman's favored long-distance weapon of
choice was believed or not a freaking
gun yeah Golden Age Batman loved to pack
heat and wouldn't get his classic origin
of losing his parents to gun violence
until Detective Comics number 33 now as
the name might imply batarangs were once
just bulky bat shaped boomerangs like
the ones used by ancient Native
Australian hunters they were meant to be
thrown than caught again on the rebound
Batman of course is an expert marksman
and in his hand they were more than a
formidable weapon it wasn't until much
later that the Batarang would take on
the form we all know and love today
something much closer to a ninja
shuriken or throwing star if you prefer
it might also interest you to know that
shriek ins despite being dangerous
pieces of metal were never actually
meant to kill instead only distract or
injure much like how Batman has used
them throughout his career
Batarang served a number of great uses
in the comics he got a gun wielding
batting no worries just throw one at him
and boom he's no longer a problem at all
got a switch he can't hit no worries
just Batarang it don't want to get up
and change the channel on the TV you get
the point I may have made that last one
up now as with most things Batman one
type of Batarang isn't enough after all
variety is the spice of life and as such
bats has a Batarang for just about every
occasion beat the rope Batarang that
helps him scale buildings you know when
he forgets that he has a grappling hook
special razor sharp ones for when he
really wants to bring the pain or wrap
them around his knuckles for extra
damage special explosive batarangs for
when he's dealing with bigger meaner
threats electrically charged batarangs
as seen in the many great DC
au shows for fighting specialty villains
and while we're on the subject of
cartoons did you know Terry McGinnis is
Batman suit of the future was so
high-tech that it actually produced its
own batarangs right from the rest
depending on the artist you're dealing
with sometimes batarangs are seen to be
foldable other times Batman just kind of
retrieves them from the utility belt
already unfurl any discussion about the
Batarang would not be complete without
at least mentioning the Arkham video
games which offer up a ton of different
takes on the famous weapon be it the
sonic Batarang or my personal favorite
the remote-control Batarang the
battering is of course synonymous with
the bat family and as such everyone uses
them or a variation on them the Robins
have their own bird orangs or wing-dings
which honestly always sounded like
something on the kids menu at a chicken
restaurant Barbara Gordon the former
Batgirl and later Oracle was known to
keep one close by and even bad woman
received her first official Batarang as
a gift from Nightwing perhaps the
biggest update to the Batarang came in
the most recent new 52 Batman Ark in
that story Jim Gordon donned the pointy
eared costume for himself the only rub
was old Jimbo couldn't throw like Bruce
Wayne after all he didn't get ninja
training so instead he helped design a
special gun that could fire batarangs
for him it worked pretty well
unfortunately when you're firing
something that big and bulky at that
speed you might as well be firing
bullets because the end result is sadly
much the same the battery is such a
recognizable and beloved piece of Batman
ephemera that whenever there's a new box
set or collection to be sold more often
than not it's paired with a replica
Batarang and you just know dumb people
out there must have hurt themselves
attempting to throw them so yeah there's
your caped history of the Batarang I
hope you all learned a little something
not the least of which being maybe don't
throw sharp pieces of metal without
proper training or you know if you think
you're gonna get caught until next time
everyone this has been Cape Jill and I
will see you next time